SPEAKER 1: Hello,
Googlers and guests.
My name is [INAUDIBLE] and
welcome to Talks at Google.
Our guest today is the
actor Manoj Bajpayee.
My earliest memories of him are
from the TV series "Swabhimaan"
and watching him set
the screen on fire,
as Bhiku Mhatre in "Satya."
It's been nearly 20
years since then,
and he has performed
many outstanding roles
in movies like "Shool," "Aks,"
"Zubeidaa," "Chakravyuh,"
"Aligarh," and
"Gangs of Wasseypur."
His craft has been recognized.
He's a two-time winner of
the National Film Award
and a four-time winner
of the Filmfare Award.
Please join me in welcoming
the very talented Mr. Manoj
Bajpayee.
[APPLAUSE]
MANOJ BAJPAYEE: Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: Welcome to Google.
MANOJ BAJPAYEE: Thanks.
SPEAKER 1: So I wanted
to start by asking--
you took a tour
around the campus--
is this your first
time at Google?
MANOJ BAJPAYEE: This is the
first time in San Francisco.
Everybody said that this
is the best city in USA.
I, personally, love Europe,
as I was speaking to my friend
[INAUDIBLE]---- we shared the
common thing about Europe.
But yes, tonight I'm
going for a look around.
Some friends are taking
me to San Francisco
and all the landmark places.
So yes, first time at
Google, and first time
in a place which is
considered the biggest
company in the world.
So yes, this is quite an
interesting, exciting tour.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
I'd like to start by how
you got into show business.
I've heard about the time
that you were a teenager.
You moved to Delhi to apply to
the National School of Drama.
You applied many times.
You were rejected,
but you persevered.
At such a young age,
how were you so focused
on one career choice?
What drew you?
MANOJ BAJPAYEE: I don't know.
I mean, since my
childhood I wanted
to become an actor, which was
quite a rarity in a small town
like mine which was quite
backward in those days,
and it still is.
We are working very hard towards
convincing the government of--
be hard to really focus all
the developmental issues
towards that area.
But yes, it was a rarity.
Being an actor was not
something that any parent
wanted for their child to
get into that profession.
It was not looked up.
It was looked down by everybody.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
For me, it was
very, very essential
to keep my dream very close to
my chest since my childhood.
So I never actually told
anybody, any close friend
of mine, closest of the body
that this is the dream I have,
and this is what I am
planning to do in life.
So it was a hard task.
Dreaming of becoming an
actor was much more easier
than keeping your dream
close to your heart
and not letting
anyone know about it.
That was very, very
difficult for me.
So the 17 and a half years
that I spent in my village,
or in the small town where
I was doing my schooling,
I kept on looking for some
avenues where I could just
go ahead and do some acting.
But it was not available.
It used to happen only
in the school functions
sometimes, one skit
here, some skit there.
Watching Amitabh Bachchan
films and imitating him
in front of the mirror.
These were the only
things which was available
to me, where I could just
go ahead and give it a try.
So for me it was
very, very important
to move my base from that
small town or that village
to a better place like Delhi.
So I thought of
doing my graduation
from Delhi, Delhi University.
That was a long, long
journey for 17 years old, 17
and 1/2 year old person who
has never been to any big city
before.
So yes, that's how it
all started for me.
SPEAKER 1: So you've kept
the dream close to your heart
as you were leaving from there.
What did you tell your parents
as you were going to Delhi?
MANOJ BAJPAYEE: The
easiest thing to tell
your [NON-ENGLISH] parent
is [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
[LAUGHTER]
The easiest way
to convince them.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[LAUGHTER]
My father was a
little disheartened,
because he had a dream of
seeing his elder son becoming
a doctor.
But he said, OK, so doctor,
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
[LAUGHTER]
That's how I convinced him.
But one thing he said
that I have six children
to take care of.
So I will not be very frequent
in sending money to you.
So you will have to really
look after yourself,
take care of yourself, of
your monthly expenditure.
So sometimes he used to send
me 200 rupees, 250 rupees
sometimes.
But the rest of the
time I was completely
dependent upon all
the friends of mine
who are doing so well now.
Some of them are into
income tax on a big post.
One of them is the Indian
ambassador in Mexico.
These friends of mine, they
took it upon themselves
to look after Manoj Bajpayee.
They believed in my dream.
Somewhere, they felt that
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
You just wear it.
I have a shirt.
You'll take it from me.
I was very short.
OK, how much you
need for your rent?
100 rupees?
So this month I'm putting in
on behalf of Monoj Bajpayee.
So that's how I was taken
care of by all my friends.
I always say that without
them, without their support,
I wouldn't have survived
in a city like Delhi.
SPEAKER 1: Interesting.
So now you're in Delhi.
You are participating
in theater.
Tell us about your
early days in theatre.
Is there a role or a performance
that you found particularly
rewarding during
your theatre days?
MANOJ BAJPAYEE: There
are many, actually.
I used to work 16 hours,
18 hours in a day.
I used to sleep for
five or six hours.
And there were many challenges.
For a person who was coming
from that kind of a place,
learning good Hindi,
because everybody says
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
So these are the languages.
And my mother tongue
is [NON-ENGLISH]..
Yes, my education
medium was Hindi.
But all the [NON-ENGLISH] used
to do very badly in Hindi.
They could hardly
manage second division.
Because [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
[LAUGHTER]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
It's tricky working on Hindi.
Learning English was
a big, big challenge.
But somewhere I realized
when I was a 14, 15-year-old,
and I was still in school, I
realized that if I have to do
well in big city, in a big
city like Delhi or Bombay,
and if I have to be in industry,
I should stop listening
to [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
So English was more of tool
for me than a language.
So English, [NON-ENGLISH],,
Hindi [NON-ENGLISH],,
or theatre [NON-ENGLISH],,
acting a craft [NON-ENGLISH],,
and monthly rent [NON-ENGLISH].
There were too many challenges
that I was facing in Delhi.
But yes, somewhere
theaters could
help me survive everything.
Whenever I used
to do rehearsals,
or I used to do plays--
anything related to
theater or acting--
somewhere I was
completely distracted
from all the difficulties
that I was facing.
SPEAKER 1: Languages is
an interesting point.
I wanted to ask you a
question about that.
You've acted in a few Tamil
and Telugu movies as well.
Do you speak any
of those languages?
MANOJ BAJPAYEE: No.
So I've done four
films, and I decided
that I will never touch them.
Because not knowing language
is the biggest handicap
for any actor.
So whenever I'm
conducting a workshop,
I always tell all the new
actors that, you guys,
your Hindi's really bad.
And you are not going to be
directed by Martin Scorsese
and Spielberg in Bombay.
You are going to
work in Hindi films.
So your language has to be good.
So Tamil Telugu films that--
very few films
that I have done, I
have realized that somewhere
I'm doing complete injustice
to my profession.
Where I could not understand
anything that I was saying.
I was taking the prompting
working on basic emotions.
Somewhere that didn't go
down very well with me.
So I stopped working.
And now I don't accept that.
Unless someone really comes
and pays me a huge amount.
[LAUGHTER]
Because as an actor--
as a star, you make a
lot of money in India.
But as an actor, you
don't make money.
[INAUDIBLE] definitely
will agree with me.
[LAUGHING]
SPEAKER 1: Another
interesting nugget I picked up
was you've actually done
voiceover work for two
animation movies as well?
MANOJ BAJPAYEE: Yes, right.
SPEAKER 1: How is
that as an experience
when you are not actually--
you just have to use
your voice to emote?
MANOJ BAJPAYEE:
Yeah, I mean, I've
done radio plays when
I was doing theater,
because that's how we
used to earn money--
200 rupees, 400 rupees,
sometimes used to make.
And I didn't find it any
different from radio plays.
Because even in radio
plays those days,
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
Or you would start working on
it, and say it in front of--
now you act it out in
front of the camera.
And this is what I have done
in those animation films.
In one, I played Rama.
In one, I played Yudhisthir.
So whatever interpretation
that I have of Rama--
because I always see him as
a human being, not as God--
but God is [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
But Ramji was married.
Ramji went through difficulties
that all humans go through.
So I treated him very
realistically for the animation
film.
SPEAKER 1: So you've worked
with many different directors.
I'm sure each one of
them has their own style.
You've worked across genres.
Is there any
incident you remember
where you were
concerned about working
with a particular
director, and you
found that as you
started working
you had instant rapport?
MANOJ BAJPAYEE: I get
along with my directors,
because I really feel that
theater is actor's medium,
and cinema is director's medium.
Because he is the
only one who has
complete clarity
about the entire film.
So you just listen to-- you
work along with the director.
You don't work separately
from the director.
You are not somebody who is--
are the people who are seen
when audience is watching,
but it's the director
who is calling the shots.
So all the people
that I worked with,
I never had any issues with any
director in my entire career.
I think also because
that somewhere deep down
in my heart, I
feel that I am what
I am because of the belief and
the faith of some directors
who somehow had the vision
of taking me in those roles.
SPEAKER 1: So you mentioned that
theater is an actor's medium.
One of the things
one reads about
is you're called upon
as the pioneering method
actor in Hindi cinema,
and other actors
look to you for inspiration.
Do you see yourself
as a method actor?
What is your style?
MANOJ BAJPAYEE: Method
is something that you--
you can't have one method.
Yes, when you're doing
theater, you are really--
you are working on yourself.
You are acquiring new
skill for approaching
each and every role.
But at the end of
the day, when I'm
working with-- on
Anurag Kashyap,
I'm applying a different
way of approaching my roles.
When I'm working
with Neeraj Pandey,
he's completely different.
He's 360 degree opposite
to Anurag Kashyap.
So an actor has to
be skilled enough
to really adjust his method
or approach according
to the director's need.
Neeraj Pandey doesn't want
you to get into the character.
He just wants you
to learn your lines
and come in front of
the camera and just
listen to his direction.
That's it.
Anurag Kashyap says, you
go through your script,
and you throw the script.
And after that, whatever
you are going to do,
I'm going to accept it.
Unless it is really, really
not right for the vision
that I have.
So a true actor is somebody
who is never questioning
the director's vision and
always ready to adjust
with the director's need.
So we apply different
kind of method
for different kind of directors
and different kinds of scripts.
SPEAKER 1: Your recent
movie, "Aligarh"--
you played Professor Siras'
character as very sensitive,
heartbreaking.
How did you prepare for that?
MANOJ BAJPAYEE: I went
the other way round.
And actually, my wife was
very, very supportive.
She has to keep my little
daughter in check all the time
and just making sure that she
doesn't come and disturb me
when I was taking
Marathi lessons, lessons
from the chief
assistant director.
He was very good.
His knowledge about Marathi
poetry and literature
was amazing.
So he used to come to my place.
And we should just learn--
I was just learning Marathi.
And this chief of
assistant director
was always amazed and surprised
as to why I'm learning Marathi,
because I'm not going to
say any line in Marathi
in a Hindi film.
But I kept on asking
him to introduce me
to Marathi poetry,
Marathi poets.
So he used to put it on
the YouTube sometime.
He used to get some link,
open it on his computer.
And I used to just listen
to those Marathi words.
And sometime, I should start
writing in Marathi, also,
whatever he was
asking him to write.
Sometime he used to make
me read a few Marathi
lines from a Marathi novel.
But for me, it was
very, very important
to think like Siras as a
Marathi literature person.
Because Siras was-- his
sexuality was not his identity.
Siras being a great
Marathi literature
professor in "Aligarh"--
that was his identity.
So I wanted to
know his identity,
to get close to his
identity, to really get
into the skin of the character.
So if you see the film, his
love for Lata Mangeshkar,
or love for Marathi poetry,
or the way he talks,
the way he approaches
his literature--
that makes Siras the character.
Gay was secondary for me.
Him being homosexual
was something very, very
secondary for me.
And that's how I
approached the character.
SPEAKER 1: Last year, you
also had three short films
I saw on YouTube--
"Ouch," "Kriti," and "Taandav."
What do you think
about that medium?
Do you have more short
films coming out?
MANOJ BAJPAYEE:
I'll be doing more.
I'm just stopped for some time,
because now suddenly there
are so many people are
making short films.
I really feel that
actor is always
in need of acting, is always
looking for an opportunity
to act.
And these short films are
giving you a nice getaway
from the routine life
of acting in films.
Just go act for a day
or two, and suddenly you
put it on YouTube.
And suddenly you see
so many reactions--
so much equal to the reaction
when you're doing theater.
It's so immediate
response you get.
And that actually
excited me quite a lot,
the kind of reaction
I got for "Taandav."
And that made me, pushed
me towards making "Kriti."
I convinced Shirish
or Neeraj Pandey
to make two more
short films for me.
But yes, I mean, you are also
pushing your limitations.
The things that you
could not do in films,
you are getting to do
in those 15 minutes.
So why not?
Just go ahead and give it a
try and learn some new things.
SPEAKER 1: I think we have
a clip from "Taandav."
Could we please play that?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: That was excellent.
That dance performance brought
to life the frustrations
of the character.
[LAUGHTER]
And it felt very
improvised and spontaneous.
So I just wanted
to know how you--
MANOJ BAJPAYEE:
Yeah, my director
wanted to do see as to
how I'm going to dance.
I said, please don't do it.
You just switch on the camera,
say action, I'll do it.
But it was a constable
who is constantly
getting pressurized by the
day to day life, the pressures
of the day to day life.
And he doesn't know
how to deal with it.
So this is the only way
he could just let it go.
[LAUGHTER]
If you have seen the film, he's
about to have brain hemorrhage.
If he'll not dance it out, he
will have a brain hemorrhage,
because he is getting
pressure from his duty,
getting pressure from his wife--
all of those things
are going on.
And he doesn't know how to
just sort out his own life.
And there comes this situation
where he just starts dancing.
And after this, everything
gets sorted out.
[LAUGHING]
SPEAKER 1: He gets suspended.
MANOJ BAJPAYEE: [LAUGHING]
SPEAKER 1: So life is back.
On the other end
of the spectrum,
your character in
"Zubeidaa," which
was based on a royal family--
MANOJ BAJPAYEE: I will
never say it on record.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
It was inspired, I should say.
That is something
rooted in history,
and it had this grandeur and
this sort of stoicism to it.
How did you feel doing
a movie like that?
MANOJ BAJPAYEE: Yeah, it was
difficult. Because Shyam Bapu,
I wanted to work with him.
He's such a legendary
director of our country,
after the late [NON-ENGLISH].
And so many films
of his really--
they left such an impact on
me when I was doing theater,
or when I was growing
up in my small town.
Those were the films, but they
were hardly available anywhere.
One show somewhere in
[NON-ENGLISH] in Delhi.
So you have to change
to two or three buses
to reach on time for the film.
But somehow you manage to do it.
And those films have really
inspired not only me,
but all the actors who were
doing theater those days.
So it was a dream come true.
And when he narrated
the role to me, I said,
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
So he said, first
of all, this role
was rejected by all the stars.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHING]
And soon, I don't have any
other choice but to take you.
But to keep you at
ease, I must tell you
that this is the photograph
of the prince on whose life it
is based on.
Tell me who is
more good-looking.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHING]
I said, definitely,
that gives me arrogance
to say that, yes, I'm much
more good-looking than him!
So he said, OK, so
you've got your answer.
The one thing that
he wanted me to--
apart from learning
horseriding and learning polo--
that was a physically
tough thing,
but one could easily do it.
For two months, three months
of practice, I have done it.
But the most
difficult thing was I
was born in a farmer's family,
middle class farmer's family.
I've never been to any palace.
I've never known any
princely state people.
So I didn't know their behavior
pattern and their mental state.
But some way, Shyam Bapu
has thought it out for me.
He said, for a prince,
he takes it for granted
that anybody who'll come to
him will bow down before him.
So you have it in your mind.
Since the time you were
born, in that kind of family,
you know that if
you get into Google,
the Google chairman will
be there to receive you.
This is something
which is granted.
This is not something that
you are going to think about.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] I'll
definitely think about
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH].
I mean, that prince will--
when he will come here,
people will naturally
come to see him.
People naturally
go to welcome him.
This is what decides
their behavior pattern.
So to get into the
zone of a prince's mind
was a difficult, difficult part.
Because my body language--
it was never of a prince.
It was never up
of a feudal lord.
Again, because I've
never seen them,
never sat with them,
never had dinner with them
or lunch with them.
So to really get into the
mental zone of that character
was very, very difficult.
But somehow, Shyam Bapu has
helped me quite a lot
through all the shooting.
SPEAKER 1: I think we
have a mic over there.
I'm going to ask
one more question.
So if there are folks
in the audience who
would like to ask a question,
please go to the mic.
You are working on your second
English film, "Love Sonia,"
which is releasing--
MANOJ BAJPAYEE: Actually, "Love
Sonia" is not an English film.
I've done two films--
they are produced and directed
by the people who are LA-based.
"Love Sonia" is one
and "In the Shadows."
"In the Shadows" is
a film that I'm very,
very proud of, because
it shot in [NON-ENGLISH]..
And I would say that it's
the best film of my career,
"In the Shadows."
And according to me, that
is my best performance.
People keep asking, what
is your best performance?
What is your best performance?
Somewhere, when the screening
was over of "In the Shadows,"
and I said, yes, finally, I give
myself some marks as an actor.
Because when you are
watching your own film--
while people are
enjoying it, enjoying
your performance,
but as an actor,
you are always looking
at it differently.
You are looking at
it very technically.
And an actor can't
tell lies to himself.
He's always thinking, I
could do better in that line.
I could do a little
better in that sequence.
So actor is never satisfied.
But "In the Shadows" is a film
where not only I was pretty
much taken aback by the craft
of the director and the story
writer, but also,
yes, I was quite happy
with my own performance.
So, yes, I'm in "Love
Sonia" as the guy--
I didn't want to
do that character,
because it was very
discomforting for me
to play a brothel keeper.
Somebody who's initiating the
lead, who is a virgin girl--
she's gotten into
big city like Bombay.
And straight away, she was
put into this brothel, which
I'm owning.
And this guy is a ruthless guy,
but he talks very sweetly--
very sweetly, he talks.
And he gets this girl
to do the stuff, which
is so, so scary for them.
But he makes it easy for them.
But he's dangerous, also--
very, very dangerous.
If you go against his
rules, against him,
then you will see hell.
All hell breaking loose.
So I didn't want to do the film.
David Womark, who is one of
the producers of "Life of Pi"--
he was kind of--
he was after me.
He somehow-- I think all
American producers are
very, very good at convincing
people, the actors.
So he somehow convinced
me to do this film.
But I'm happy that
I'm part of it.
Though I don't like
myself in the film,
because the character
that I played in this film
is something which
gives me creeps.
But yes, I'm very happy that
these two films are ready.
And they are going to
take festival routes,
and then they will be
releasing in India.
SPEAKER 1: I think we have
an audience question here.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Manoj.
MANOJ BAJPAYEE: Hi.
AUDIENCE: So arguably, two
of your most defining roles
have been Bhiku Mhatre
and Sardar Khan, right?
What are some of
the challenges you
had while preparing
for these roles
and bringing such
reality to screen?
MANOJ BAJPAYEE: When I
was given Bhiku Mhatre,
I really didn't know
how to go about it.
Because just before
Bhiku Mhatre,
a couple of years before
"Satya," [INAUDIBLE]
is a film that left
such a huge impact
on each and everybody's mind.
And all the actors
were completely
blown away by the performance
of Mr. [INAUDIBLE],,
who I personally think
is one of India's finest.
And he's never gotten his due.
So when I was doing Bhiki
Mhatre, I was very scared.
I always had this fear that I'm
going to have an [NON-ENGLISH]
kind of a syndrome while I'll
be playing the character.
So I had to go
completely against him.
So to prepare the role, I
went into the back story
of Bhiku Mhatre.
I prepared a back story
of Bhiku Mhatre, which
helped me to really sketch
out the approach or the method
to do that route.
So that's how Bhiku
Mhatre happened.
And also, Anurag Kashyap--
the script gives you a
lot of scope to improvise.
And Ram those days
was very open.
He said, just go ahead
and give it a try.
And if it is really
wrong, I'll cut it.
Otherwise, I'm going
to keep everything.
So all of these guys
together and the back story
of Bhiku Mhatre about
literally little things--
if I tell you, if you
remember the film--
like when I get into
the house of Bhau, who
was just played by Govind
Namdeo, I touched his feet.
So Ram asked me, why
did you touch his feet?
So I said, in my back story,
after my father's death,
he is somebody who helped
my mother, to bring me up.
And that's how I
am with him today.
I'm working for him.
So for me, he's like
a father figure.
Oh, let me go for
a close-up then.
So he took a close-up of that.
So that's how Bhiku
Mhatre kept on happening,
kept on shaping up everyday.
It's never one person's effort.
It's very collective.
Sometimes directors
are so welcoming.
And they keep adding
little, little things
to your preparation,
which is amazing.
And Sardar Khan-- when
I was hearing the script
from Anurag Kashyap,
he said, Bajpayee, I
don't want to see
Bhiku Mhatre in this.
I said, this guy is not a mafia.
He said, no, no, he's a mafia.
I know, and for me,
he's a womanizer.
So I have never treated Sardar
Khan as a dangerous guy.
I treated him as somebody who
is always looking for cheap sex
all the time.
So if you see the film,
that's how I prepared myself.
Even the body, the
raw sex appeal.
I went for-- well,
I requested, Anurag,
please allow me to
have a bald head.
And for a few days,
he was not ready.
And suddenly one fine
morning, he got up, he said,
Bajpayee, let's go for it.
So we have done everything
possible which could actually
enhance his raw sex appeal.
And also, the way
he walks, the way
he talks to a woman, the
way he looks at a woman
is not something I
have ever experienced.
So to get into the
zone, in one shot,
Anurag Kashyap said,
Durga is sitting there.
She's making roti.
And you have to look at her
in the most perverse way.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHING]
And that shot has become
quite a landmark for people.
And they keep asking me,
how could you do that?
[AUDIENCE LAUGHING]
So yes, for that, you
have to be an actor.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHING]
[LAUGHING]
I know, because there
are certain reactions.
Every good actor, like
[INAUDIBLE] is sitting here--
in many ways, she's my senior.
And she will agree
with me that there
are many, many of the actions
that an actor achieves,
and sometimes even actor doesn't
know that it actually happened.
It actually-- it just happened.
It just happened in that shot.
It just happened.
And everybody clapped.
And every actor has this memory.
And for that shot, I realize--
I remember Anurag Kashyap
looking at the monitor.
And he said cut, and
he came and hugged me.
And it just happened.
And if you asked me how
could I manage to do it?
The most perverse reaction?
Believe me, I have
never chased a girl.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHING]
As a small village boy, I was
very scared of telling a girl,
"I like you."
I always thought that
she's going to slap me.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHING]
So for many years, I
couldn't date a girl.
So you are talking
to a person who
has this kind of a life story
and who has done Sardar Khan!
For me, he's quite
an achievement!
[LAUGHING]
SPEAKER 1: So it was interesting
to learn how you distinguish
Bhiku Mhatre being a
gangster and Sardar Khan
being a womanizer.
What was your
character from "Aks"?
What were you thinking
of him in these terms?
How did you think
of his back story?
MANOJ BAJPAYEE: Rakeysh Mehra--
he told me about the script.
And then he said,
I don't want you
to play character in this film.
I want you to play evil.
So evil is a metaphor.
If I tell an actor,
you have to play evil--
now, evil has too
many facets to it.
You can't just say
that evil is dangerous.
Evil is most flamboyant.
Evil is most attractive.
A bottle of liquor is far
more fascinating looking than
a bottle of
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH],, right?
So why they make it
fascinating looking?
So that you buy it,
and you drink it.
And if you get lured
very easily by any bar--
but when you get into a
bar, it's all dark, dungeon.
You don't know when you're
going to come out of it.
You want to come out.
You want to say, this is
the time I should go back.
This is a time I should
go back to sleep.
But you don't come out.
You keep on dancing.
You keep on drinking.
So that's evil.
So that was my point for the
characterization of "Aks."
So if you see the film,
he's very flamboyant.
He's a very good lover.
He's very attractive.
That's why the long hair was.
He is sharp.
But there is something very,
very dangerous about him.
And that something
you only get to know
when he starts laughing.
That is the only sign where you
realize that this guy is not
trustworthy.
So that's how two, three
months of preparation
has gone into making Raghavan.
SPEAKER 1: I think we have
another audience question.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Manoj.
My name is [INAUDIBLE].
I'm a huge fan of you.
So my question is, these
days, a lot of period films,
biographies are
coming in Bollywood.
And you do a lot of research,
a lot of hard work for it all.
So is there any famous figure
or historical personality
you easily identify with
yourself, and you have a dream,
or you want to play
that character?
Do you have any?
MANOJ BAJPAYEE: I would
like to play Chanakya.
AUDIENCE: Chanakya?
MANOJ BAJPAYEE: Yeah, I
would like to play Chanakya.
I really feel that he's the
biggest philosopher of all.
And he's not been
read until now.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE]
That will give me a chance to
really do research on Chanakya,
who is known as Kautilya.
So that will also give me a
chance to know all the text,
know everything about him.
Because whatever little
that I know of him,
I think he's somebody who should
get his due by the filmmakers.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: Another audience?
AUDIENCE: Hello.
This is more of a complaint.
There are movies like
"Gangs of Wasseypur,"
"Aligarh," "Budhia
Singh" that did not get
released in the Bay Area.
MANOJ BAJPAYEE: You are going
to talk something which I'm
going to answer very brutally.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHING]
AUDIENCE: Yes.
And then you made a
very fine distinction
that there's a difference
between an actor and a star.
The star gets all the
money, the actor doesn't.
So what are you as an actor
trying to do to become a star?
MANOJ BAJPAYEE: See, you
have to understand one thing.
AUDIENCE: Can I say something?
MANOJ BAJPAYEE: Yeah, please.
AUDIENCE: I think
Manoj is probably
one of those rare examples of
an actor who is truly a star.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE]
MANOJ BAJPAYEE: Thank you!
Thank you.
A star is when-- you
don't become a star.
I really feel that way.
Stardom just happens to you.
But actor-- you have to really
work hard to become an actor.
You can't work
hard to be a star.
Stardom is not something which
can be achieved by hard work.
All you can do is--
but I wanted to be part
of these kind of films.
I always saw a dream where I'll
be playing these roles which
are in of our day to day life.
And they are the
heroes, whether it is
Biranchi Das of "Budhia Singh."
When the news of "Budhia
Sing" was coming out,
and he is going to
run the marathon,
it was covered widely
by all the channels.
And I was quite fascinated
by this coach who was--
swich on one channel, he is
being regarded as the villain
by one channel.
And he is being regarded as
hero on the other channel.
So that interested me.
I said, what a
personality this man is!
He's such a
contradiction in himself.
Whenever I saw him
talking about Budhia,
I also saw a very arrogant
man and a very innocent man.
So this combination of arrogance
and innocence of Biranchi Das
really attracted me.
And when I was offered this
role, I immediately grabbed it.
I said, I must do this role.
There is a dream.
There is a dream that one
day, entire Indian audience
through all the world
will be standing
in queue to watch these films.
There is a dream.
And I'm working on these films
with the dream in my mind.
It's not happening.
Our audience is failing
us all the time.
It's not the producers
who are failing us.
It's the audience
who is failing us.
But should we fail ourselves?
No.
We can't afford
to fail ourselves.
We can only go on doing
what we believe in.
We should go on
doing things that
will one day fulfill our dream.
Now, that dream doesn't die.
Dream only dies when
[NON-ENGLISH] people die.
This dream will always be there.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE]
Like you stand in queue and buy
the first day for sure ticket
for [NON-ENGLISH] film.
The dream is there that one
day, you'll be standing in queue
and buying the first
day for sure ticket
for those content-driven films.
That dream is there.
And so many actors, so many
filmmakers are working on it.
They have the choice and options
of making other kind of films.
But no, their
belief is into this.
And kudos to them.
They sacrifice so many other--
there are so many other
comfortable things to do this.
So the day audience
will wake up,
the day they start
going to the theater
to watch these films, that
will be the day you will start
seeing a different
kind of a change coming
in the Indian industry.
And then Indian industry
will become a global force.
Because until the time we
are not focusing on content,
we can't compete with
the world cinema.
We will always be
regarded as Bollywood.
Bollywood.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHING]
So stars-- they get money.
And rightly so, because
their films are doing well.
And producers are ready to
invest money into their films,
rightly so.
But should we stop
doing our job?
No.
We should be doing what we are
good at, or what we believe in.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
My name is [INAUDIBLE].
First of all, welcome
to Google, Manoji.
MANOJ BAJPAYEE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: And I hope you have
a wonderful evening in San
Francisco, since it's your
first time in the Bay Area.
My question was around--
obviously, it was very
inspiring to hear your story.
It seems like you're a
very hardworking actor.
You've learned a lot--
not just languages, but
a lot you've picked up
in the due course of your life.
There's one thing which I
have noted in your movies--
very offbeat.
You have played very
different roles.
I really liked the
diverse roles you
played in "Aligarh," in
"Gangs of Wasseypur,"
and in "Special 26."
I wanted to ask if there is
a way, or advice that you
would give people within Google,
how to spark their creativity.
If you can just talk towards
how you've experienced that.
Obviously, there is a story
which the director brings
to you, but you, as an actor,
also add a lot of creativity
into it.
So any advice for us
on how to really spark
that creativity in
each one of our jobs?
MANOJ BAJPAYEE: Thank
you very much for asking
this question, but the one
thing I always stay away from--
giving advice.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHING]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
I was listening to
[INAUDIBLE] one day.
And he said,
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..
[AUDIENCE LAUGHING]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
I'll try to answer you
through my own preparation,
how to spark your creativity.
I personally-- I can
consider myself a rebel.
I get up in the morning.
And if I think of going
in the park alone,
I don't listen to my wife.
I just go in the park.
Sometime I think of taking
my daughter in the market.
I immediately do it.
Listening to your
heart, not your mind.
Listening to your heart
is the beginning point.
Judgment-- judging people.
I don't judge them.
I don't [NON-ENGLISH].
I don't judge my characters,
the characters I play.
I don't judge.
And somewhere, these are
all the morality issue.
These are the issues.
There must be some points where
I must not be compromising on.
But I don't look at
people's life or the world
with any kind of judgment.
I don't sit on a pedestal
and look at people's life,
or look at people and the world.
I am always listening.
Be it [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
tweet,
to anybody who is unknown, who
is giving abuses on Twitter.
Just reading, listening,
reading, listening, absorbing.
Human behavior, human
behavior pattern--
these are the things.
If you keep it alive, keep
your eyes and ears open--
for me, that starts the
spark of creativity.
Until the time
this, all of your--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
And I'm not judging anything.
I'm letting everything
come into me.
The creativity will be alive.
And maybe that will give
spark to the creativity
that you are talking about.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: We have a couple
more audience questions.
AUDIENCE: Manoji, many of
your fans here at Google
sent us many requests,
but the biggest one
was for you to share
some of your dialogues.
MANOJ BAJPAYEE:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
AUDIENCE: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
MANOJ BAJPAYEE:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
The moment I finish
the shot, and if you
ask me to just go back again,
I'll have to again memorize it.
So [CLEARING THROAT].
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[AUDIENCE LAUGHING]
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE]
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
Because I have taken--
I actually learned a lot from
[NON-ENGLISH] rhythm of his
speech.
I learned a lot, because--
I keep listening
to [NON-ENGLISH]..
Or there are many other
leaders or many saints, so
many speakers.
Because they really help you
in formatting a speech pattern.
So with the
"Raajneeti" dialogue,
that speech was actually mainly
I have put in all the things
that I've learned from
Mr. [NON-ENGLISH] speech.
So if you remember that--
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE]
This was actually taken from
Mr. [NON-ENGLISH] speech rhythm,
speech pattern.
And that I have put into this.
[NON-ENGLISH].
So I'm very bad.
If you tell me to say any
dialogue that you remember,
I will just say it.
I'm very bad with it.
One thing I really admire
about [NON-ENGLISH],,
that he remembers
all his dialogues.
And anytime you ask him to say
any dialogue from any film,
he just says it.
That skill-- I don't have it.
AUDIENCE: Hello, Mr. Bajpayee.
Welcome to the Bay Area.
MANOJ BAJPAYEE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
He was the great
actor in the '80s.
We knew him.
We knew [NON-ENGLISH].
And across the aisle, we had
Smita Patil and [NON-ENGLISH]..
These days, we have
[NON-ENGLISH] and Nawazuddin
Siddiqui-- you, of course.
And who's across the aisle?
And if there's nobody
really strong over there,
why is the case?
MANOJ BAJPAYEE: Actually, no.
I disagree with you.
Konkona is very good.
And one actress sitting
here, so you can't say it.
Pallavi is there.
Konkona.
Kangana, I think, is a
remarkable growth as an actor.
Kangana's journey actually
is quite inspiring,
not only for the female
actors, but also male actors.
Because you can really
educate yourself.
You can actually create
a discipline for yourself
without getting into
any kind of institute
and become a very good actor.
Kangana is a very
good example for it.
So there are so many actresses.
Why we only remember
Smita Patil?
Because she left us very soon.
And we wanted to
see more of her.
So that longing of seeing
more of her is still there.
[NON-ENGLISH] is
a great actress.
[NON-ENGLISH] of that
time, [NON-ENGLISH]..
There are so many
other actresses.
But yes, it would have been
fantastic if she was around.
We miss her.
And that's why we keep thinking
that we don't have somebody
like her, because
she was Smita Patil.
Definitely, we will never
have anybody like Smita Patil.
But at the same
time, I really feel
that there are so many
fascinating actresses working
in our time that we
can learn so much from.
And they are doing
films, and they
are performing on their
own terms and conditions.
So we are in a very
good time in that way.
SPEAKER 1: I understand you're
in town for the FOG India Day
parade.
Can we roll the video for
that please, for the audience?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Celebrate the 25th anniversary
of the Festival of Globe from
August 5-13.
Enjoy the free India Day fair
and parade with Grand Marshal
Manoj Bajpayee in
Fremont, California.
Join us for FOG Movie Fest
with World Premiers, FOG Idol,
Real Estate Expo, Business and
Technology Summit, The Youth
Innovation Fund, Freedom Fighter
Reflections, Culture Fest,
Fashion Fest, and a star-studded
red carpet furthermore.
Visit fogsv.org
for more details.
[END PLAYBACK]
SPEAKER 1: So I hear
you're going to be
grand marshal in the parade.
Tell us more about the
event and your involvement.
MANOJ BAJPAYEE: I really thank
Dr. Japra and the entire FOG
community for really
giving me this honor.
I have never been
to this parade.
I have heard about it
from the fellow actors.
So I'm looking forward to it.
And whatever that visual
that you have shown us--
I mean, I know it's going to
be quite a fascinating journey
and a colorful event.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[AUDIENCE LAUGHING]
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE]
So looking at those
visuals, suddenly, I
realize that yes, the clothes
that I got made is just right.
[LAUGHING]
So I really thank Google for
giving me this honor to sit
on this platform and address
some questions from you
and from the all the Googlers,
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]??
Fellow Googlers, yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you so
much for coming here.
It's been a pleasure.
MANOJ BAJPAYEE: Thank you.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE]